hello hello
hello this is the person who cut me off
in traffic last week yeah
yep i was in the gray jaguar you cut me
off then flipped the bird that's what
happens don't mess around with me
don't play dumb i took down your license
plate and tracked you down
yeah good morning i said yeah it was me
yeah i'm not playing dumb
i would like an apology so i can just
move on with
my life thank you very much
i apologize to you for uh for not doing
it fast enough and not
not doing it in a manner that humiliated
you further oh my god
just apologize why do you insist on
being such a bloody
i think it was your father that told me
to do that actually i think it was
are you really going to make me come
over there and force an apology
yes i told you i took down your
license how are you going to deny it
when i when you ask your mum i have your
address i'll just find you myself
be outside in 20 minutes just knock on
the door man because i don't
your neighbor was the one who cut me off
not you um
listen i'm sorry i'll make it why didn't
we
drink it it was it was your daddy when
he was
you have to understand because